Malcolm do you think that the original P
tape dossier will prove to be true well
we know what he's talking but he's
talking about Christopher steal that
where he claims that there was the tape
where prostitutes urinating on the hotel
band Trump did address that with Comey
yeah yeah you know I said this on TV the
other day but there was my point it's a
riot the team sure but you know all the
horrible things that were in the dossier
you know alleging that he was going to
get a nineteen billion dollar payoff
from Ross nav alleging that he was going
to be spying on Russian oligarchs in the
United States all of these things you
know you should not be calling the
former director of the FBI ongoing no
the P tapes not true right
I said it's a great day it talked to the
hookers right the rest of that drain is
bad right it's delicious right and he's
already sort of inoculated on that issue
we've already seen the Hollywood access
tape if people elected them after that
the hookers is less okay let's see Eddie
what is your favorite country to perform
in and in which yet that's fascinating
you perform in four languages what are
the languages Spanish German French my
French is pretty good like wow yeah I'm
getting that Spanish just started but
got a mazing range of countries I can go
and play but comedy is so delicate I
mean it's hard to do it in your own
language okay how can you do it a
language where it's not your first
language
it just works I mean I've got this joke
in English sees a job at Julius Caesar
did he ever think you would end up as a
salad and and in French is exactly the
same CSS Collegium I imagined a college
in LA on salad and they laugh at exactly
the same place and in German the verb
goes at the end of the sentence was even
weirder but it still works says I had a
yogurt actually ever think that's air
iron mal that he one time as the Latin
inverter as salad end up would have and
they still even though the verb is right
at the back they still get it they still
love everyone gets it human is human and
not national references are the things
that screw it up Wow
Alex how would you define fake news is a
great question first of all by the way I
love Eddie by the way I used to watch
your stand-up special with my dad also a
Breitbart editor by the way right
dressing like a woman before the school
at school so I don't some dressing like
women I just say these you know I'm just
I'm just wearing clothes you know like
women when they wear pants they're not
dressing like men anymore so and
lipstick and eyeliner and yeah I'm just
going for equal rights for everyone
I love the male so for fake news it's a
great question and there's a real
definition for it I think that the left
tried to make fake news I thought the
goal was going to be anything that's
right of center anything that people on
the right want to talk about not the
left and the right
quickly reappropriation it to anything
that was the least bit false that a
establishment or left-wing outlet put
out so that's the parlor trick that's
what the right did is they saw the word
fake news the left is going to use this
to harm us potentially use it to get us
banned from social media or demoted from
social media and the right said we have
to take this term back for ourselves and
I think they did what effective job but
that was a lie because fake news was
things that people knew when they were
writing them were absolute [ __ ] they
were putting it out there just to
confuse people because people read and
they don't check things out and then
they share it and we saw that like the
thing about Hillary Clinton running a
child sex ring out of a pizza party or
that's fake news right that's different
than what what Trump caught with Trump's
definition of fakes news is just any
news I don't like what so not quite
I sort of have a bone to pick with you
your Breitbart right and you don't do
fake news that's what you're asserting
here yeah you know there was this
article about 35 year counterterrorism
expert who claimed that they want to
Trump Tower attacked that was written in
Breitbart
I got 31 death threats from that and
that came from your website so you're
going to secure that right now you can
apologize to me to say I'm sorry to say
I think I spent decades hunting
terrorists yes oh that's fake as hell
you don't have to share your bonafide
ease with me I respect you I respect
your serum your followers threatened my
family my children my wife are you
really suggesting that Breitbart doesn't
get death threats that our lives aren't
putting under nonono you can apologize
to me now all right I'm not threatening
you a story and if this story as you
describe it I'll be happy to offer I
will worry I will come to your office to
see that retraction okay I would love to
see it Jenny that's the case I think
megyn kelly should an interview Malcolm
by the way was liked by both sides of
the aisle until Trump became president
and he became a hysterical person like
you are and so this is H am sorry you
know on the right he's a user
now he's demanding apologies for me for
a story print out the store that isn't
historic now that's just him getting
angry at 31 best friend welcome last
night you know this man is not
hysterical I in this anger this is a
song he called one of the key members of
Trump's administration gurbles it's a
anyone who's comparing that's not Trump
white out you I call the little baby
baby girl okay
[Applause]
I'm causing him death threats when he's
caught he's saying people on my side of
the aisle or Nazis okay in the meantime
you guys raise e people shooting up a
Republican baseball practice where that
is not exactly calling someone and not
see Alex don't I'm sorry
yeah yeah great good no because girl
what gurbles was a propagandist I think
that's the message here for yes for the
Nazis yes I understand me well okay well
okay let me let me say something
something I'm gonna just say something
that Hitler said if you lie big enough
people will believe it and that's why it
seems to extremist I'm very good at if
you lie big enough and that's it I throw
in a lie and what you did I've got to
say even though you like my stand-up
when he said could you please apologize
for this you've moved into spitting it
around and bringing in the shooting
recently and sort of and it got very
muddy very quickly which is a technique
I feel that is used somebody said
something this is a problem and they say
arbiter this other problems I mean we do
in the UK as well they get up in Prime
Minister's question time someone says
will you tell me about this and say well
what about that that happened a year ago
and then it all gets muddied and that is
the first thing you do in that situation
is take away the heat and say let me
look into it I understand that way the
first lady's jump and I would say that
exactly I had people to jump me all the
time online and you know when I do I
have a troll of the week because I don't
have any followers and I find the one
that I think is kind of most offense at
the end of the week I'm like here you
were the most effective troll in other
words yes there are a lot of people out
there spewing hatred call the [ __ ] down
I mean you need to calm down right yes I
am I'm saying we're all only responsible
for ourselves and all we can do is take
responsibility for the way we respond
when people go nuts so if you thought he
was then you calm it down you don't say
oh I can bring it I saw senator Warren
come out the other day and say Trump
hasn't begun to see nasty yet that's not
useful I mean come on you'll agree with
that right let's let's not go there
right Ted Nugent come on the show
[Applause]
not calling us Nazis in fact gracious
yes well there are the last time we saw
this happen with the 1930s and that's
when they were out and doing it and they
did raise again if you watch what
happened in Germany it was at the the
the center center left they're all
fighting amongst each other and it got
very extreme and is it fair dr. violet
them you can cook I mean the Nazi thing
did happen and you can compare someone
to Hitler without the part about killing
all the Jews for example Donald Trump I
think is very similar to where Hitler
was not leaving that part out like in
1942 when Hitler was going crazy and the
High Command right was like oh my god
what are we going to do because he's
telling us that we can't withdraw from
Stalingrad that seems seems to me where
people are in the Republican Party are
going to with Donald Trump now now I'm
saying he's an anti-semite I'm not
saying anything else about the
comparison with Hitler but I mean this
is a this is a historical entity that I
don't think can be completely off bound
and it doesn't it's not saying we're
comparing him to Hitler in that way
isn't that fair I I don't think that
that's fair at all and I think that you
can keep you can keep using these
tactics but Trump and the Rasmussen poll
today 50% I don't think it's working for
you guys so please go ahead keep
comparing us to Nazis and Hitler and
we'll see how it goes for I agree with
you I don't think he is Hitler I think
he's George the 3rd and 1783 and by the
way the cherry-picking
right that's the Rasmussen the fact that
you know you'll go and you'll take that
with the most equitable bar which is by
far the outline I mean people these
people you act as if the the audience is
stupid
and that's not useful right I mean they
will play well to your base so again if
it's about money and cliques I get it
but at the end of the day I mean it's
really important to bring it sound like
you also not all out know if you watch
Trump of course I mean the level when
he's putting out tweets he's talking
about his polls
I mean it's astonishing the the level of
stupidity that he presumes of the people
that are actually following him and yes
it works but it really damages our
country
okay how about last question it was
sorry it came up for over Chuck I'm
having fun all right we'll wait shirt
funder will will will traffic will trump
fire Robert Mueller definitely silence
on the board I think he might I think in
my mind if he gets angry enough sure you
know I mean he's proven that he's not
going to go by the rules that everyone
else wants him to the establishment
media everyone else I think if he feels
like no one's gonna stop him I think if
he gets approval from his base all right
if he starts reading Breitbart comment
sections Miller's debt
all right let's leave it there because
we're
[Applause]